Xi Jinping has visited Russia eight
times since becoming Chinese president
his most recent trip was in June 2019
during an economic Forum c will travel
there again this week in what's expected
to be a major show of Chinese support
for Moscow as it continues its invasion
of Ukraine
with China and Russia working together
the world will have the driving force
toward multipolarity and a greater
democracy in international relations and
a global strategic balance and its
stability will be better insured the
visit comes as China seeks to expand its
role as a global leader and mediator
earlier this month it brokered a deal to
end seven years of strained relations
between Saudi Arabia and Iran
thank you some analysts believe it can
do the same for Russia and Ukraine in
February Chinese officials released a
peace plan calling for a ceasefire and
dialogue between both sides the Chinese
understand news after several months
most parties are exhausted and they want
to have the Forum to start Peace Corps
technical offer large and no other
country can do that but others say
Beijing is reluctant and unable to play
this role due to the West's extensive
backing of Kiev it is great power
geopolitics going on there it's very
difficult to to play a mediating role in
that context and uh the stakes are very
high
Russia and Ukraine do not want to
negotiate at the moment so there is very
little China can play with
Beijing relies on economic trade with
Europe and says it's impartial in the
war but its claims of neutrality has
been questioned last year C declared a
No Limits partnership with Moscow
expanding trade between the two
countries has become an economic
Lifeline for the sanction hit country
she and Putin are also good friends and
have met 40 times including on Putin's
birthday
the United States says China is
considering providing Military Support
to Russia which Beijing denies she is
reportedly planning to speak to Vladimir
zielinski following his Moscow visit it
would be she's first conversation with
the Ukrainian president since
hostilities broke out Kiev says it's
cautiously receptive to beijing's
involvement but a withdrawal of Russian
forces from any occupied territory must
be included in any peace deal Katrina
you Al Jazeera Beijing